[Music]
heylia thank you for asking me about my
day you know what do I do at NASA one of
the things that I love about being a
scientist is that I don't really have a
typical day I do lots of different
things so for example one of my duties
at NASA is thinking about the
communications thinking about all of our
websites and our Twitter accounts and
our Instagram feeds all the ways that we
get our information out to the public
right now at NASA we have over 100
active science missions everything from
Rovers on Mars to the Hubble Space
Telescope to missions to Jupiter to
earth science missions that are tracking
for example how the ice is melting in
Greenland and every single one of those
100 missions is putting out wonderful
information in making discoveries and I
want people to know about them I want
people to meet the scientists that are
doing this wonderful work so I actually
try to manage all of the different
information that's coming in from all
these missions and find a good way to
get it out to the public and then I
track and see how many people are liking
us on Facebook and I mean was that press
release particularly successful so I'm a
scientist that has specialized in
communications sometimes I go on trips
I'll be doing talks for example at a
conference you know somewhere in in
Europe I actually love coming to the
United Kingdom
sometimes I rarely for me but I do still
do some scientific research so I've been
to telescopes all over the world
when I was getting my doctorate I mainly
use telescopes that were in Australia
and South America and also in Arizona
Kitt Peak and I use things like the
Hubble Space Telescope so you know
sometimes you're actually traveling
somewhere to make your own discoveries
and then going back to your office with
your data and working on all of the
different measurements you took and
trying to make discoveries out of that
it's also very important for scientists
to share their discoveries you know if
you make a wonderful discovery at a
telescope but nobody ever hears about it
then that was basically a waste of time
and money for you to do that so we write
about our discoveries in scientific
journals other scientists read them and
then we can collaborate and science
moves forward because we always work
together as a group and nothing in
science happens individually you're
always working with people so you're
going to meetings you're talking about
you know how are we going to fund a new
spacecraft we've just been on a
wonderful observing campaign we observed
a new kind of star what happens next you
know who's gonna make follow-on
discoveries
one of the things I love about being a
scientist is working with really
passionate wonderful friendly people and
and planning how we're going to continue
the science that we've started so I love
not having a typical day my husband for
example is an engineer and he actually
builds and tests spacecraft so but
normally in his day he's wearing
something called a clean suit and that
is a white plastic suit that covers all
of you you know your hair your face and
everything so that as you work on
spacecraft the spacecraft keep entirely
clean and he always texts me on his
iPhone a little bunny symbol when he's
putting on his bunny suit we call that a
bunny suit your clean suit so he's
always building and testing spacecraft I
do have friends who are astronauts and
the astronauts will spend their day off
in training for a mission and this is
wonderful to watch I've had a chance to
watch some of this one of the best ways
you can train for working in
zero-gravity actually floating around in
space is you train in water because
water allows astronauts to float as if
they were weightless and so in Houston
we have an entire full-sized mock-up of
the space station in a giant pool of
water and the astronauts go down in
spacesuits to practice how they're going
to fix the space station or how they're
going to install a new instrument on the
outside and so you can actually watch
them going underwater with a team of
divers to help them and make sure that
they're safe and practicing what they're
going to do in space so there's a
wonderful range of things to do I mean I
joke and it really is true that I bet
80% of my job is the same as practically
any other job there are meetings there
are budgets there are weekly reports to
do there's answering email there's all
kinds of stuff that isn't very dramatic
but what has never escaped me as far as
being a scientist is that sometimes it's
absolutely brilliant you walk into a
room and there are scientists talking
about the latest discovery and it blows
your mind or you watch astronauts
training for their mission or you get a
chance
to go to a telescope all by yourself and
make a discovery nobody else has ever
made
so maybe my job is 80% mundane the same
as everybody else but there's 20% of
creativity and brilliance and working
with the best people I know and that's
the real reason I love being a scientist
[Music]